hey guys today we're going to talk about
how to fix tennis elbow right so let's
just pretend that she has tennis elbow on
the right side okay now here's a secret
never work never never never never never
never work on the same side I know it's
weird like so many therapists they work
on the same side and it takes months and
months to get better work on the
opposite side now before I tell you how
this works I'm just going to show you
what to do okay what you're going to do
is you find it where it's hurting on
this side and you press on the mirror
image so let's say the mirror image is
right on the top part we're just going
to massage this now you could do it on
yourself okay but you could also press
have someone do it on you and just show
them how to do it and watch this video
so you rub that right there okay so that
should get rid of the pain right there
but the key is getting the mirror image
exact spot when you rub this now the way
you know you have the exact spot it'll
be really really really tender
okay you'll find one spot that person
will go ow that hurts
well then we just spend time and work
that out but we're not done yet we have
to work on the muscle connected to the
elbow going up don't worry about going
down just going up so we're going to
work on the elbow and then we're going
to work on the muscles on the opposite
side and you're going to work on the
bicep and the tricep okay on the back
part and you're going to massage these
right here okay now why does this work
because the hip bones connected to the
thigh bone this arm is connected to this
arm through a circuit through the spinal
column we have a stuck flow by the brain
the brain is sending pain signals over
here it's stuck
okay to free it up we can work on this
side and that forces the brain to focus
on the other side and lets this go
that's how it works it's very very
simple but it's one of the most magical
things for tennis elbow the key is like
it might go away like 80% but then you
ask okay where is it now well and it
moved
higher or a little bit more over here
and you keep tracking it down and doing
the opposite on this side until all this
is completely gone all right so do that
for probably every night for like week
or two and you should be fine but if you
still have the problem there is a chance
that it could be a tear okay this will
not fix the tear you're going to have to
go and get it scoped and get it sewn
back whatever because this will only
work if there's pain that's stuck there
okay so that's how you fix tennis elbow